and the last remaining medal of honor
recipient from world war ii died last
week today it was announced that
herschel woody williams will lie in
honor inside the capitol building the
date and other details are to be
announced at a later date west virginian
woody williams died wednesday at age 98
he earned his medal of honor in the
battle of iwo jima at age 22. williams
was never one to take credit though
i've been in
the medal of honor society since 1947.
but most of them will say
it doesn't belong to me
i wear it in honor of those
who never got to come home
and sacrifice their life i walk in the
footprints of somebody else i was born
free because somebody gave his life
to make it possible for me to be born
free
after world war ii woody served in the
marine corps reserve and worked at the
v.a helping fellow veterans for decades
the huntington west virginia va medical
center was actually renamed in his honor
and there is something thematic and
consistent with world war ii veterans
and it is that completely selfless
nature of always deflecting credit and
putting it on others it's really a
beautiful thing i i notice it
in countless interviews we've heard with
veterans i noticed it with my own uncle
jack who served in world war ii they
always want to give praise to others
what an honor though and also to just
have it you know just to be announced
today just gives it a whole different
meaning yeah absolutely agree with that